this morning we're exploring a cuisine
known as california soul it springs from
the mind and experiences of chef keith
corbin he says he got his taste buds
from his grandmother but his culinary
talent was almost lost to a life of
drugs and crime corbin gave lilia
luciano a tour of the los angeles
neighborhood where he grew up and shows
us how he's now giving other members of
the community an opportunity to shine
keith corbin is one of the country's
most acclaimed new chefs
and the creative force behind alta in
west adams los angeles here he cooks up
california soul food a fresh modern take
on the staples of his childhood i don't
care
who is the creator if you're creating a
dish with the intent to nourish and
stain and feed the soul or someone
you're so full but his story starts in
watts south los angeles i always say no
matter
how high my tree grow or
where it bends and hovers over my roots
are always in the same place walking
along grape street the memories come
rushing back
including the near death encounter that
made him leave gang life for good what
happens here so i was coming by and it
was early in the morning like eight the
gentleman jumped got out of the car
and literally shot the car up that i was
in with my little brother and my
four-year-old nephew but thank god
nobody was hit as a grape street [ __ ]
hustle came to define corbin around the
jordan downs projects he's still known
as fresh
but among hollywood and music industry
elite he's chef you're fine with mac and
cheese in the kitchen at alta he invokes
the soul food flavors his grandmother
brought west during the second great
migration just cooking with love taking
the time being patient feeding the
community that's how we do it his
gripping new memoir california soul is
filled with tales of brotherhood and of
gang violence and of his granny's sweet
cakes i've never ate dinner growing up
at my granny's where
i didn't have a piece of cake at the end
this is where i spent all my days i used
to sit in and sell drugs out to get
through school corbin spent almost a
decade in and out of prison i came home
from prison the first time i see my
peers having things that they had that i
felt that i deserved
so i jumped back in the game and it was
in prison where he excelled and built
community working in kitchens
so when a restaurant opportunity came in
i got a call from my mother boy you
better get over here they hiring
acclaimed chefs daniel patterson and roy
choi brought local to the food desert of
watts to feed and empower locals a
concept to bring
food
from the philosophy and ideology of a
chef to underserved communities full
deserts to bring a good quality food at
affordable prices
it eventually shut down but after
spending years perfecting his skills
corbin eventually partnered with
patterson to open alta prison
cooking didn't prepare me for this
cooking drugs didn't prepare me for this
though it pays off on every single plate
i have to start with the thing that
takes me back home the red beans
it's good right that's that love see
okay so what goes into this
just garlic onion chili flake
and smoked oil even his gumbo is a fresh
reinvention and the heart of his
culinary point of view combining
california produce with southern soul
where you want to go
i'm going gonna go for the gumbo right
here you have squash you have corn
you have sweet peppers you have a little
kale at alta he met his wife renee
what was it like for you to read
california soul oh that's a hard
question
when i read those pages i lived that
story with him he says she saved him
from his last great demon addiction it
was also healing
because you know to see how much we've
overcome together looking back corbin
says his journey is not his alone he
sees it as a blueprint for others i
don't hire for colon blue
i hired from the project
we have a high turnover rate yes
and it takes a lot of time and patience
to train these people that have never
had a job before and it's like if
we don't do it
who will nobody the most important thing
or the most powerful thing you could do
is to do it over and over to say i'm
here that's it not quitting on you
yeah he keeps coming back sharing the
stories
and importantly the dishes i'm no expert
but this is perfection for cbs mornings
i'm lilia luciano in los angeles
you know what's good guys when you want
to lick the screen you bravo to chef
corbin and his wife renee who he said
saved him from his last demon but you
can clearly see he knows what it's like
to have a second chance too and look
what he's doing and he you know he's
paying it forward he says he doesn't
hire from court on blue he hires from
the projects uh his mom was the one who
called them and said you better get them
down they're hiring you can't see your
mom's right calling you up and saying
here's an opportunity for you and then
his wife and all these people that even
as he was falling were there to catch
him and now he's doing that for others
food is a way to show love that's what
he sees and it's so true yep and how do
you go wrong guys when every meal ends
with a piece of cake
i love anything well i got it i want to
try this gumbo because when they were
describing it i'm like kale it's
california gumbo there's a local
ingredient
that's right i'm going there nicely done
lily i want to go to that restaurant i
go to la too i know people there